it's gonna be great it's gonna be
awesome we have a blast come on let's
bring it in bring it in let's get a
picture
hey Li yeah we're here for the charity
event and the entry is a suggested
hundred dollar donation and I was just a
much lower number is there an open bar
yes Oh dumb stupid is dumb you guys are
fighters here you go tiger
oh there's Harbaugh dang it it's okay
Jim we just having fun the charity
what's call he different mechanics
polling is different you think LeBron
James would be good at Papa Schadt this
guy I'm getting this this guy's killing
me there she is
let's do it
Oh yum yum this looks delicious I can't
wait to have more slicing ah sorry
you each have a pepperoni on your face
damn it oh crap how embarrassing
first we donate $10,000 to charity and
now get pepperoni on our faces I'm sorry
you probably get this all the time but
is anybody ever told you you look just
like Emma Stone no I was thinking Riley
Claire VP of Marketing Little Caesars Oh
actually yeah I am Riley Claire oh my
goodness I mean so embarrassed like to
donate 10k eat and now this the Sam do
big family do they had hi how you doing
Tim cranwell two aforementioned creme of
duvae advertising we would love to work
with you someday
oh well actually we are looking for a
new agency that said well look no
further you found the perfect guys for
the job
had heard that here say it give me that
watch this I don't mind telling you
where the two best day I've been in the
city but we're also big fans of your
Little Caesars Pizza oh thank you the
smell of one of your hot readies
instantly takes us back to some of our
greatest childhood memories and not just
for us but for everyone we know what you
couldn't walk 50 miles in any direction
from the spot we're standing in right
now coming across a birthday party
graduation or an anniversary isn't
serving a great big Iping high yeah
Little Caesars Pizza Pizza
you